Nice beard.
Help!
I am help!
I'm Maeve's friend.
He is her complicated
love interest.
I love you.
Oatcake, you alright?
I'm A-OK, Eric.
I'm fine. I'm chillaxed!
To the max!
OK then, Mr Moustache.
So you guys didn't speak
much over summer?
No.
And I haven't heard
from him since last term.
I always thought
you two would make up.
We're not fighting.
We're just not
friends anymore.
An on-campus sex clinic
for teenagers is
rather entrepreneurial,
in my opinion.
It shows a lot
of business savvy.
We don't run
the clinic anymore.
We've realised,
it wasn't very ethical.
-And we--
-We stopped being friends.
We grew apart.
Oh. That's a shame.
So why aren't
we friends anymore?
Nice beard.
What's your point?
Nothing.
We're just
in very different places.
It's called a moustache.
Yeah, no shit.
We need to tell Hope
she can't teach this stuff.
It's backwards.
She's not gonna listen.
We need to do something.
Like what?
I don't know.
Maybe we could help people,
like before.
You mean take their money?
That wasn't the only thing
the clinic was about, Otis.
What else was it about?
I'm not getting
involved anymore.
It's not my problem.
It's not your problem?
Why?
Because you're too cool now?
You don't need to care?
You didn't want to do
the clinic either, Maeve.
Yeah, you're right.
And now I remember why.
I'm going to the library.
This trip is the worst.
Can't get much worse
than a rogue poo.
Where's the coach?
It's getting dark.
It's gonna be cold
once it's dark.
I'm panicking.
Are you panicking?
No, we're not gonna
starve to death, Otis.
I don't think you're taking
this seriously, Maeve.
-We could die.
-We're not gonna die!
Someone will drive past
and we can use their phone.
-It's gonna be fine.
-We should hitchhike.
OK.
How do you say "help"
in French?
How do I say "help"?
Help!
I am help!
Why are you laughing?
Sorry. You're just really
funny when you're stressed.
Well, you're
not helping, Maeve.
What did it say…
the voicemail?
Doesn't matter.
It was ages ago.
Matters to me.
It was something like…
"Hi, Maeve."
"I'm watching you
on TV right now."
"And I wanted to let you
know how proud I am of you."
"And about how you saying
you had feelings for me
was all I ever
wanted to hear…
because
it's always been you."
"I love you."
I mean, anyway,
it was stupid.
Did you mean it?
Of course I meant it.
I can't-- I can't do this.
OK.
I understand.
I don't--
I don't wanna
lose you again.
I know. I'm confused.
This is confusing me.
Oh, Milburn,
you're here, too.
We had no idea
you were missing.
So sorry.
Come on, guys, on the coach.
On the coach!
Maeve.
Yeah?
We should talk
about what happened.
Is it OK
if we don't tonight?
I need to sort my head out.
That's OK.
I'm sorry.
I just wasn't expecting
what happened
between us to happen.
-Yeah.
-And, um…
I like Isaac.
You know, I think
we have something good.
OK, I'll meet them there.
You OK?
No. I need to go to Anna's.
There's an emergency.
OK.
-Do you want my bike?
-No.
-It's quicker.
-I can't ride a bike, Otis.
-What do you mean?
-I can't.
No one ever
fucking taught me, OK?
The police are here.
-Hi.
I wanted to make sure
you were OK.
Thank you.
-What are you doing here?
-She needed a lift.
That's convenient.
-And what about buses?
-We thought about buses too.
And you can tap her phone.
Sorry. How are you both
connected to the case again?
I'm Maeve's friend.
He is her complicated
love interest.
You used to be her friend
until you were an arsehole
at that party.
I think
the only arsehole here
is the man
who deleted my voicemail
without telling her--
Right. Outside, both of you.
Outside.
-Yep.
-OK.
You're always popping up
where people don't want you.
-Just go home.
-You don't know me.
You're always
making things worse.
What are you
even doing here--
Shut up, the pair of you!
My sister is missing.
This is not
an opportunity for you
to swing your dicks around.
I don't know how you could
think of choosing this guy.
Choosing? What are you
talking about "choosing"?
You're so deluded.
Oh, right.
Something happened between
you guys on the trip then?
Ye-- Yeah.
Look, it doesn't
mean anything.
I mean, I…
I don't know what it means.
It's just, Elsie's missing.
That's all I care
about right now.
Well, good luck
finding her, Maeve.
Isaac, don't go.
Fuck.
Thanks, Otis.
I think
I should stay and help.
No, I don't think so.
You make things worse.
What do you mean?
Since stopping the clinic,
you stopped caring
about anyone but yourself.
No, that's not true.
It's just
not my responsibility.
I think you should go.
I don't wanna
see you anymore.
Maeve.
It was never
about the clinic.
I did the clinic
to be close to you.
And then you made me realise
I'm good at something.
And I like helping people.
And I thought
you ignored my message
and it crushed my heart.
I stopped the clinic because
it reminded me of you
and it sucked.
So I wanna help people.
And I know this is only
about money for you,
but let's just
be a team again, please.
If I can't be with you
romantically,
I still wanna
see you every day.
Nothing feels right
when you're not around.
It wasn't just
about the money for me.
I wanted to be close
to you too.
-Maeve!
-Good morning.
Good-- Oh, my--
Good morning. Oh, my God.
What are we gonna do today?
Hey.
What are you doing here?
OK.
I've changed my mind.
About what?
America.
I found the money,
so I'm going.
Right.
When?
Now.
Wow.
-Yeah.
-Oh.
You know you don't need
my help with the clinic?
It's your gift.
Yeah, and what about us?
We'll have to see where
we're at when I'm back.
I'm proud of you.
I mean it.
-America.
-Yeah.
So this is goodbye.
No.
It's "see you soon."
OK, cool. Wish me luck.
OK.
Bye, Eric.
Bye, Maeve.